over three generations the
rough-and-ready Gracie's from Rio de
Janeiro have spread Brazilian Jujitsu
across the globe and become a dynasty as
the unchallenged first family of martial
arts what's up guys how you doing advice
is very important learn and grow there's
someone in the back who's gonna tell you
some advice that hopefully it will stick
with you you could take it implement it
learn from it run with it boys Gracie I
did not develop a sport I developed my
style for self-defense or jujitsu it's
like what the samurais do without the
weapons we perfected taking so much weak
people like me and anybody else can
benefit boys Gracie who proceeded to win
three of the first four Ultimate
Fighting Championships once I'm on the
ground she fights practically over they
don't know what to do like I fought a
boxer that got in a pinch I took him to
the ground and he just quit he knows
he's in trouble boys gracie how are you
doing
how you doing guys so what do you think
for someone who's new we just met
someone you greater gave him some great
advice he was saying I just started
training jiu-jitsu and I'm getting beat
up on what you know and then you gave
him some good advice share that with us
I told him hang in there
and tough while you're the in view so
you can hit hard when you become the
hammer so it's a just take it for now
one day you'll be giving the other piece
of advice we're talking about the
importance some people get to a level
this is not just a jujitsu but in life
in general we talk about learning
growing talked about that's very
valuable man I don't believe that you
learn everything in school so it's
constantly learning I tell my kids all
the time
don't let school into the future
education I'm just today I learn a bunch
of stuff over here from you guys so it's
a constant learning process it doesn't
stop it doesn't have to be
oh I'm not learning the math when we say
to physicals beyond the mat it's like we
never stop on the mat today then we're
learning from each other
beautiful thank you hoist we'll see you
again in Chicago saw Michael hey it is
Beast
you